[Music]
all right
so someone on redditch asked
what's an unexpectedly well-paid job
crab fishermen what how much do they
make over six figures
because you die oh you could it's the
most dangerous that's why it's called
the deadliest catch
it's the most dangerous job in the whole
entire world
but it's also very rewarding because
it's money yes
any other unexpectedly well paid jobs
you guys know what oil rigging oil
something deep something older those are
unexpectedly
because i feel like those are like you
expected i expect the oil
so like so like like garbage man that
type of stuff
garbage can viral tick tock kid
i thought that's what i expected one
would be like a dog walker
because you think of it as a part-time
job depends who's who's the owner
voter ballot counter okay but do they
get paid well or is it just like
arbitrary guessing now
guessing oh yeah no like it's like a job
that you get surprised
like um like an in and out manager they
make over six figures
or they like make uh hundreds oh
internet managers in here
so i have a list of them see i was right
so the first one on the list is poop
patrol workers in san francisco what's a
poop patrol
oh no the homeless make sure the
homeless guy don't take a [ __ ] on the
floor
they go around the city and clean up
human feces that's their official title
yeah so once
when they're at a a a a dinner party and
someone said what do you do what do you
do for a living what do you say
they're literally called poop patrol i'm
on poo patrol i'm sheriff poop
nice to meet you so much a pleasure
the homeless problem is bad true so
these workers
are entitled to 71 760 dollars a year
and an additional 112
9118 in benefits jesus no i mean because
you might get hepatitis cleaning up the
kaka
what is a hundred and twelve thousand
dollars in benefits
they're like here here's your salary
here is a
mercedes-benz as well keep cleaning the
pool or the freaking health insurance
that's how expensive it is yeah exactly
or just living in [ __ ] san francisco
true trying to buy a donut there is like
holy [ __ ]
true so expensive anyway second
job here is a closed caption broadcaster
for the news they make up to 72
000 a year which you mean someone's
actually typing that [ __ ] yeah
they don't have it on ai yet that this
job's going away soon i mean
all the closed caption on youtube is ai
but it's not even accurate it is so
not right yeah most of the times yeah so
this person on
uh they responded to that reddit post
and said i work at home as a closed
captioned broadcaster for the news i
make my own schedule and make between 35
to 65
an hour depending on the job large
investment to get started but
significantly worth it but like what if
they do backstabbing
backspacing while you're watching it you
go click
and they delete and you're like the [ __ ]
bro well i don't think well based off
this comment it's not live based off of
the comment here
because they're saying my mistake the
whole time you're just imagining someone
just like
a stenographer just typing away no but i
think they probably do have that because
the news is
live what about the presidential debates
it's live they have that the main
question is why did they get rid of that
breaking news dad depends on which
channel you watch right
i don't watch tv i never saw that except
for in movies same
i've seen it you have you swear in my
memory
oh no that's the worst place to source
it well like the
the really annoying like
emergency broadcast
the one that's like this is not a test
this is not a test
don't you love how we had that whole
system and then on 911 they didn't even
use it
yeah yeah did they even use it the
emergency broadcast system they weren't
like
hey uh new york center attack any i
don't remember any of that [ __ ] i just
remembered a tower maybe it was local
well they didn't say that we were under
attack until remember
it all happened afterwards because it's
like they were like oh a plane crashed
into a building oh it was just like
that's that my recollection was yeah oh
that sucks a plane crashed into a
building
it wasn't like no but then by the time
the plane crashed into the pentagon
and stuff like that that's when it
became an attack yeah well no it was the
second point second plane first
and then we were all like oh [ __ ] yeah
then it's like that's not a coincidence
right
two and then building three yeah an
invisible plane crashed that one and it
fell
tower seven power seven yeah yeah cia
building that one yeah it's like why
huh where they kept all the wall street
golds so there is another
building that the planes didn't even
crash into it's called building seven
it's on the side in the world trade
center so wtc
tower seven and it was an independent
building of the two towers what
look into that [ __ ] demolition
and larry silverstein said pull the
building just saying on if you can you
can listen to it on a broadcast and he
was the owner of the
twin towers yeah pull the building which
is vernacular for
demo in that in that community but you
know
just fun stuff just fun stuff fun stuff
oh no
i have to say though if you saw the
fires on this on the other side of wtc
seven it wasn't just like
it randomly fell over like it was it was
there were significant fires in the
building
but we would never ever be a 911 denier
because that's not what we are because
because there's no way there's no way
i know 9 11 happened yup but as a denier
no that's not uh no no no no no
are we making this into a conspiracy no
uh what's going on though like
what happened here today number three
garbage collectors in new york you
mentioned
uh they make more than one hundred
thousand dollars a year
i believe that i like that that's good
any um
union job it's pretty really well paid
it's a valuable
job too dude why don't they teach us
this in school i would have been a
garbage collector then
you would have yes instead of making fun
of garbage collectors which is yes
i looked down upon garbage collection
you did that's because of how school
geared me to look at that that's what
they did
they're like what do you want to do you
want to collect garbage for you exactly
you say that [ __ ] all the time you want
to be like the janitor and then he's
like
oh [ __ ] yeah exactly jennifer's making
six figures hopefully now
the [ __ ] i would totally do that and i
have a college debt
[ __ ] yeah as a concept of fairness the
idea of like picking up trash and
getting paid well for it makes so much
sense
yeah definitely blue collar jobs should
be paid well very necessary
number four in and out manager up to 160
000 a year damn that's tight how about a
lint licker it announces
always popping though they're popping in
and outs are oh
they always have lines they should get
paid well they should get yeah
i remember being in high school and
hearing like in and out was
the best minimum wage job to go to
because
they don't even pay minimum wage it's
like ten dollars starting off like an
entry level job
yeah entry level because like back then
i think the minimum wage was like 675
for my first job and they were already
paying more than 10. yeah they pay hella
good right now that place runs like
clockwork too dude i've never seen them
[ __ ] anything up
i've never had a wrong order there right
everybody's smiling and happy
that's why they deserve what they get
paid but the fry cooks should be [ __ ]
fry cook fire slash it yeah get rid of
that job
yes [ __ ] your fries just stop selling
the fries they're horrible fries you
like in and out fries
when you get them light well no no what
does that mean no that means they cook
them
a little bit longer no it doesn't matter
i don't know can animal style it you
could do whatever the [ __ ] you want to
it i think it's bomb when it's not light
well
terrible is it too like potato and soggy
no it's too cardboardy
potato ask for it to be a little what
did what kind of fries do you like
seasoned fries don't count like make a
dinner mcdonald's is different though
you know why
because this is how they make them you
mash it up first
and then you put other things into it
and then you create a fry
shape really yes they don't just chop a
potato up
i call that craftsmanship huh that's
craftsmanship artisanal fries you're
right though
remember when we were in japan we got
those really really really really long
fries
that's kind of like the concept where
they have the fry
gun thingy and then they just line and
um line them up
like that one and then you got a really
really really really long potato chip
lawrence yeah
now i'm just thinking about churros you
got the right ideas for very long
you got the right idea what is a true
potato churro they don't nobody knows
what is in the church
nobody actually knows churros there's
flower
we're like yeah yeah what's in it it's a
dough pastry
you put the cinnamon and sugar
afterwards like you
you squeeze it like you have the star
thing at the end of the bag
and then you have the dough that's like
flour in specials
and then like you squeeze it into the uh
fryer
and it comes out to the cheeto shape and
it spins
and then you take it out and then you
put cinnamon and sugar on top
and that's what we asked we said how do
you make a churro and then the tongs you
gotta go like this
yeah you know originated in spain and
portugal
it's not a mexican thing no and then
they made their way to mexico yeah i
think you like dip it in chocolate or
something
they stole it from spain and portugal oh
just like how they stole the fact that
spain
colonized mexico yeah exactly oh
oh so spain stole mexico and mexico
stole
churro exactly they're like you're gonna
steal the land
i'm gonna steal the pastry [ __ ]
an eye for an eye how about that
[ __ ] stupid
okay number five a technical writer they
make over a hundred
thousand annually what the [ __ ] is that
yeah what is that
so a technical writer is a
is a professional writer that
communications
that ends up making like manuals like
instruction manuals
or user journal articles quick reference
guides
um my grandfather did this technical
documentation
china into the chinese ones and all they
need to be fired and
re-trained because the chinese manuals
suck kia's like i refuse to hire one
yeah i like ikea's one no
i thought that that's maybe they made it
easy for anybody dumb to do it yeah ikea
is really simple when they show you like
like not one cartoon character doing it
it's like two yeah they don't even need
to have writers they just need
drawers i'm always like draw the whole
thing out i'm like you said the hole's
right here but the hole is actually not
right there
hey y'all i'm not talking about sex
though
i'm talking about ikea furniture i don't
care
i know exactly where the hole is for sex
dude
he said for sex he doesn't
i know where it is i forgot a
massachusetts bay
transportation authority worker make
over 100k a year oh what a what
transportation
a massachusetts bay transportation
authority worker
so like people that that do the the
metro line oh but you know these jobs
though
they're um if they're union jobs like
it's pretty
you got to know somebody to get in it's
not like easy
no but some of these the some of these
don't even
you don't even need like high school
experience no but
i'm not talking about qualifications
like to be a longshoremen out here to
work a union union job
like not a teachers union or a police
union but these special jobs
in most cases they lock it down with
friends and family
oh i see what yeah i feel like that's
like any job
though and the turnover rate for these
things are probably very low too very
low
so just the fact that for an oath
waiting for an opening you'd be waiting
your entire lifetime
well that sucks used to be mob connected
[ __ ] too
yeah the mafia
[Music]
[Music]
you